[Music] it's Austin Matthews world and we're
just living in it this weekend on this first
Friday of February we welcome you to the 2024 NHL
Allstar skills presented by DraftKings Sportsbook
scoa Bank Arena here in Toronto man everywhere
you look a superstar to be found and they'll all
be showing off their skills to the world tonight
all the big boys are out there in a rather relaxed
and fun atmosphere looking to put on a show you
can't walk a couple feet without bumping into
an NHL icon like Nathan McKinnon as you welcome
you upstairs I'm Steve Levy alongside Ray Ferraro
welcome everyone to the continuing Allstar
Weekend a year ago we're on the beach outside
a tiki bar the Elbow Room in South Florida other
than it being colder there's another difference
it feels different here in Toronto this year uh
it really does I mean let it's the center of the
hockey world here in Toronto and there's the most
media the most attention it comes to this place
the fan lineups uh in the in The Fan Fest or
you can't believe how long they are it's been a
really amazing start to the weekend and least it's
about fun and this is fun it's been great Ray you
played 35 years in the NHL one Allstar appearance
tell me about this what was going on here I'm in
the skills competition I scored on Tim Chev at
Detroit four times a week earlier and I used the
same move well apparently he had the book and
he stopped one I mean I I think I get the last
one here I was terrified being in the allstar
game actually I missed out you didn't get the
last one no you weren't supposed to be watching
but I was terrified being in the skills because
I wasn't sure that I really felt like I belonged
I like you try to do your best you don't want to
fall down you don't want to embarrass yourself it
was the best what was the date on that again okay
it was January 18th 199 he remembers the exact
date in Philadelphia Emily Kaplan is with Will
Arnette Emily yeah it is good will you're here
you're wearing your leafes hat you're with Conor
McDavid and Leon dyle on your team what are you
looking forward to and who are you rooting for
tonight well it's fun it's fun being here with
obviously Connor my my co- captain and Leon
who's my uh my assistant uh it's good seeing my
assistant doing well there's my guy right there
come on there's Conor he's just a killer and then
uh this is so exciting I'm a fan right so I'm just
here I just met when Clark for the first time
in my life this is I am flying not like bé but
I'm like are we allowed to is that out there it's
out there it's out there okay um no I'm just here
I I'm literally giddy I just met Wendell Clark
in an elevator not how I thought it was going
to happen but uh it's just so cool being around
all these players all these Elite hockey players
it's just I feel like I'm 9 years old it's going
to be awesome BCI back to you all right Emily I'm
here with Mark Messier played in 15 All-Star games
mess in had $1 million been on the line when you
took part of the skills what would that have done
what will it do for tonight it it would have been
massive and of course a million dollars is a lot
of money from where I came from but it's not going
to be as big as being able to have a chance to
be crowned as the NHL's most skilled player I
think that's going to Trump the million dollars
in my opinion I think the competitive edges are
going to come out and we can debate all we want
about who's the best skill but we're going to
find out tonight if you ain't first you're last
tonight 1 million bucks to the winner we are
live in Toronto Ontario Canada for the new and
improved NHL skills competition here on ESPN new
and improved format if you haven't heard here's
what it's all [Music] about get ready for an all
new NHL Allstar skills challenge where at the end
of the night we'll Crown a single Champion here's
how it works 12 Allstars will compete across the
first six events earning points as they fly around
the ice in fastest gator whip pucks on the net
in one timers put it on the tape in the passing
challenge smash Pucks in hardest SHOT show off
crazy control in stick handling and nail Targets
in accuracy shooting the top eight will then take
on our Allstar goalies in a one-on-one Showdown
the top six skaters to get past the goalies
will face the eighth and final ultimate skill
challenge the obstacle course A Champion will
be crowned and take home the $11 million prize
alongside Mark Messier I'm John Butcher
gross and these are the 12 dudes who will
be competing for one million as Ricky Bobby
said if you ain't first you're last there's
no second place prize here are the 12 dudes
in the ESPN bet odds to win no surprise mess
Conor mcdavid's the favorite well could you bet
against him he's obviously the most electrifying
player in the National Hockey leag he has been
for years now he's the fastest skater he's got
the most Talent he's got the most skill he's got
the best hands so to rule him from winning this I
don't think the uh odds makers in Vegas are that
naive to think that he's is obviously a favorite
to win tonight and of course the NHL wanted to
improve the skills competition after the last
couple of years they went to Conor McDavid
to get his input some of these competition
tonight or drills he does in the summer like
the stick handling drill well I think for me
the interesting part is uh to see these 12 players
the 12 best players or 12 of the best players in
the National Hockey League compete in this event
to see who could be around the the League's most
skilled player and I think that alone is going to
carry a lot of weight these guys are competitive
anyways but they have the chance to carry that
mantle around as a League's most skilled player
I'm not going to say it's going to Trump in the
million dollars but I think it's going to come
close to trumping a million dollars there and
I think it's going to be exciting because of
it competition number one is the fastest skater
McDavid certainly the odds on favor to win that
he threee in this event between 2017 and 2019 the
only person to ever win it back to back and so to
get off to a good start start tonight and get
those five points for first place here are the
participants for the fast and all fastest skater
and you see the odds to your right McDavid a huge
favorite I think that McDavid if he enters
into this and he really puts his heart into
it he puts everything he has into it I think
he's going to win this event I think his other
players obviously they're very fasf but he can
carry the momentum in the corners better than
anybody in the league and we've seen that over
and over and over again of course we have data
for top speed and average speed of an NHL game
William nander actually owns the lowest top speed
of this Bunch so he's a big Underdog and here he
goes participant number one for the evening and
participant number one in the fastest skater
competition here he comes down the [Applause]
stretch so William neander finishes his lap the
clock for some reason didn't stop so we'll have to
figure out where it was when he crossed the line
so we we could have our first review of the night
we're have our first review you can see when he's
coming around here it's all about being able to
carry the speed through the corners as you can see
him going around there his legs given out a little
bit or skates his edges given out that's costing
him time if you can carry the corners at full
speed and come out of with actually faster than
going into it h you got a chance to win this event
you can see right somewhere right there maybe
that wasn't the right one but one of the corners
he kind of took a little bit of a stumble so we
want to get an official time before Quinn Hughes
goes so 14.16 4 the time to beat for now
you can choose which direction you go mess
which direction did you go back my left
side going going to the left was always
my better Side Y okay I think for most
lefties it is cuz you carry your stick
to the inside so I think you'll see most
left-handers go uh go to the left captain
of the Canucks Quinn Hughes American maid
played college hockey at Michigan for the
Wolverines I don't know what they did to the
Hughes boys there but all three of are amazing
skaters see if he beats neander he does so he's
currently in first place I think we got to get
to the high 12s low 13s to win this event in my
opinion well we step it up now with Ma barzel
and McDavid they're in a little bit different
league but of course last year we saw marar
fall in Florida well that's the thing is it's all
in the corners this is going to win or lose it in
the in the terms so McDavid who is going to go
last will now wait for a couple more skaters
let's not to underestimate how difficult it is
for these players here with not a real proper
warmup as well you think falling Downs on his
mind right now after last year no absolutely
not great players don't think about things behind
them he'll be going left over right look at the
power in that stride right there all right he
makes sure he makes that first turn that is a
strong stride little coasting on the corner
as it's going to cost him oh so jues hangs
on look how close that is kale marar
is now in second [Applause] [Music]
place five points for first four for second three
for third 1,000th of a second Quinn Hughes hangs
on so that that matters as you're trying
to accumulate points with each competition
tonight and we'll keep a running scoreboard for
the folks at home and that's the most exciting
part about it is that everything matters every
little point that you can get scrape out there
could be the difference of winning and losing in
the end Matthew Barelle 2020 champ he comes the
closest to McDavid in both top speed and average
speed categories during NHL games this year and
you can see him on that first turn Flawless
through the turn there a little hiccup there
in that third corner there but the first oh
that was easy yeah there we go easy peasy
yeah so that's the time McDavid
has to beat so Quinn Hughes does
slot down one but he's guaranteed at
worst third watch him take this first
corner here never stops his feet
moving there accelerates out of
[Applause] it who little speed wobble there
so Conor McDavid knows the time to beat that's
going to be a tough that's going to be a tough
score to beat got to watch Conor on these on
the first uh first two turns here McDavid the
odds on favorite he has reached the top speed
of 2358 mph this season his average speed this is
where he excels look at that that this just looks
different look at his feet never stop moving never
stop M looks different never stop moving well oh
there's a winner winner chicken parm dinner the
ability for him to hold the edges in the corners
at top speed is what separates him from most of
the players of the National Hockey League and
that was on full display right there he grew up
in the Toronto area he did Nick a couple pylons
mess but those things are light didn't affect
him at all didn't affect him fourth win in this
competition most all time he can uh like I said
if he puts his if he puts his heart in to it and
he really goes for it I don't think there's a
faster scar in the National Hockey League and
this is why right here watching his feet through
the corners but being able to hold the edge at top
speed a lot of strength a lot of skill a lot of
practice but Nobody Does it Better that's going
to be a tough time to beat so there's six primary
events in round one the player picks which four he
wants to go in so David poock and William nander
who of course finished finished fifth in that
Matthew barzel just gets nudged out but he'll get
four points yeah exactly after after competition
number one yeah you just got to get get some
accumulate some points coming down to the end
every little bit you can scrap together is going
to make a difference and again McDavid was looking
forward to this new skills competition he said I
think after last year everybody agreed a change
was in order I think crowning just one skill
Champion with a little bit of money 1 million
bucks should make it a little more entertaining
and a little more comp competitive hopefully he
was clearly competitive there mes you when you
when you just watch that that was 100% from every
player that just competed in that event there's
not one person that mailed that in that that's
that just goes to show you what they're what
they're competing for absolutely PK suban is
with the fastest skater Conor McDavid all right
ladies and gentlemen here with the fastest skater
in the world Conor McDavid and the best player
Conor first of all tell me a little bit about t
Toronto and what this means to you to be at the
NHL allstar game in in your hometown it means a
lot to me um you know obviously this my hometown
this building means a lot to me grw up watching
the leaves here um special to be here in front
of friends and family great hockey Town um just
a great event and like I said happy to be here in
my hometown you know you come out here you prove
once again that you're the fastest skater in the
world how do you do it how do every year you come
back and give these fans what they want to see
you do it every game but every all start game
you're here you step up and you do it how do you
do it uh you know what it's been a while since I
won a past a skater a couple years ago I didn't
even win an Edmonton so we got some good skaters
in Edmonton I guess but you know it feels good
to win obviously we're all competitive out here
competing having fun um yeah just happy thank
thank you Conor thank you Conor McDavid fastest
man alive the skills competition continues
from Toronto a new competition in this year's
skills the onetime A Perfect Blend of patience
power and precision tonight that's all on
display in the NHL onetime competition our
Allstars will take three one-timers from each
of three designated areas and points will be
awarded based on where the puug enters the net
sneaking in upstairs get four points score
into those two triangles earn three points
or put it right down the middle and get two
if a puup ricochets off one of the dividers
they'll tally one point but if the shot hits
the bottom barrier a post or the crossbar or
misses the net entirely they get nothing each
player gets one minute to fire all nine shots
if a pass is not to their liking they can let
it go but can only get five total passes at
each location and if a stick breaks the clock
will stop most points win the challenge let it
rip passers for this event the first overall pick
of the 2023 NHL entry draft number
98 for the Chicago Blackhawks Conor
Bard and playing in his six NHL allstar game
the captain of the Pittsburgh Penguins Sydney
Crosby so it's the one-time competition these
are the players who chose to participate in this
again these players will pick four of the first
six competitions M I think the onetime or goal
is the most exciting offensive play in hockey
it's explosive it happens out of nowhere and
these dudes can all bring it they can all really
shoot the puck there I I look at uh David poso
and Austin Matthews has been the two favorites in
this uh competition they're all great obviously
but those two to me are natural goal scorers and
we've seen it all year the way they can score
in many different ways but their one-timers are
some of the best May probably the two best in the
league and as you saw introduced Sydney Crosby
will be one passer he's left-handed and Connor
Bard being right-hander will be a right-handed
passer so Elias Patterson can really bring it
so it's you're looking for obviously to score and
there's different score totals depending where you
put it each player taking three one timers from
each spot on the ice top of the circle now at
the dot that's a post that zero point then he'll
move to the bottom of the circle a maximum of five
passes you can take a pitch you're allowed to take
a pitch like in the Home Run Derby and you can
see Pon not really taking a full Slap Shot he's
more almost like a almost a snapshot but uh very
little back swing and that's prob for accuracy for
more accuracy exactly so 20 points for pson and
again this is not so much we the hardest shot
competition later that's more about obviously
miles per hour this is about accuracy and point
total just shooting off the pass it doesn't have
to have a big wind up in order to get it off and
this is to your point it's all about the accuracy
and getting into the top portion of that to
collect as many points as you can so peton going
first he's now on the lead so as you can see our
live standings he's projected with five points now
those aren't truly earned until the competition is
done but McDavid got those five in the fastest get
McDavid not in the one-timers pon poock Miller
Matthews McKinnon coocher off dry setle barzel
so Bard passes to the righties Crosby passes
to the Lefty so it's Bard to Nathan McKinnon
well McKinnon I'm sure is going to have a little
bit of bigger wind up there and uh not so much
actually they're kind of slow passes here to
help them gather and snap and go for a point
obviously a pass with a little less Pace on is
much easier to time and get a good good uh your
good blade on or good wood in we used to say in
the old days but you can see mcken there very
accurate yeah that top blue bar is what you're
looking for and you can see he has picking it
off picking off didn't like that one again you
can take a pass that's really important for the
passer to make sure that buck is coming to
fight you can see it rolling a little bit
which makes it a little bit hard but that's
he was so he takes the lead with 23 points
Bard and McKinnon don't forget these players
are looking for that top shelf all time cuz
they know they got to shoot it over the goalie
stick so when they're practicing this onetime
you know obviously in their practices they're
going for that underneath that crossbar all the
time so Sydney Crosby returns to pass to the
left-handed Leon dry Sidle hard to Discount
Leon dry Sidle when I pick Matthews and
Passa not because this is one of the best
ones with with McDavid feeding in the passes
all year long but we'll see how he does he's
got one of the biggest blades in the in
the league great shot there these guys
will be Olympic teammates with that great an
announcement today mass at the NHL going back
to the Olympics in 26 and 30 and Conor Bard
and Nathan McKinnon could be linemates one
day you asking every one of those players do
they want to play in Olympics they'll say yes
so I'm glad they agreed that they're going to
send the players and it's a great opportunity
for every one of them Leon dry side he's
probably the king as you mentioned of the
power play onetime getting passes from McDavid
mostly so 23 points from McKinnon the score to
beat yeah he gets passes from McDavid all
year long and I was get pass Crosby in this
all sort of game pretty cool not too bad huh
he only goes top shelf when he's at the bar
look at the big long stick he has there he's
got a good angle on this sure enough that's
pretty good so 22 points for dry Sidle that
puts him in front of Pon but behind McKinnon
yeah McKinnon was eating up that top shelf
and that's where the points are going to be
made if you can get it up there you also
risk going over the net but unbelievable
Tru from that [Music] angle looks easy watching
it at home BCI but when you get down on the ice
with everybody watching the nerves are there
it's not as easy as it looks what a year for
Nikita COV being Lefty once again he'll take the
passes from Crosby one of my favorite players in
National Hockey League to watch his offensive
Acumen is incredible that's what we want back
scratchers that's a true onetime yeah he's not
letting it oh there he goes he I think that's
what the NHL envisioned with this it's really
they didn't expect a onetime to be a bunch of
snapshots two-pointer there got to get those blue
ribbons that's what McKinnon did so well a career
year for Nikita COV 32 goals 53 assists 85 points
in 49 games he'll take that pass from Crosby
oh Coo's got to pick it up here
yep so a disappointing 17 for
Nikita kucherov oh looks like it's going to be
19 so McKinnon holds on to his lead he's gun
him for that Five Points that's what happened
there he hit that crossbar top there didn't get
anything out of it that's right cross barss are
zero that was unfortunate so you see the
shooters who remain as McKinnon looks on
if there's a tie then they'll split the points
so they'll be four and 1 half and four and a
half if someone happens to tie M kinon at 23 JT
Miller what a year he's having in Vancouver the
Canucks just got Elias lyol PK suban sit on
the point he's their team to come out of the
west of course the West is loaded that was a
massive pick up for a Vancouver L tremendous
hockey player plays a 200 foot game can play in
any situation good in face good in the power play
now they got a right hand drive on that power
play already that's been so a dynamic JT Miller
born in East Palestine Ohio and he could be
a little bit of a sleeper in this competion
wow there's a four- pointer mess from top of the
circle yeah he's shooting with a lot of velocity
too very accurate shooter always with a high
shooting percentage doesn't have to have volume
to get his goals well he's a big strong kid and
I'll tell you what he's got a lot of skill that
it's on display the last couple years in Vancouver
and I got to know him a little bit when he was
with the Rangers good kid plays hard plays with
a lot of [Applause] power so JT Miller with 18
yeah he missed a net a couple on the high it cost
you he doesn't doesn't do that in the game no he
doesn't and now you hear the crowd come to their
feet the greatest goal scorer currently on the
planet is a kid from Scottsdale Arizona on Pace
for 70 goals this year am amazing and it wouldn't
surprise me if he does it to do it but the power
and the skill that he plays with is unmatched in
the National Lo league and he is definitely the
League's best goal scorer right now 26 years old
grew up in the desert went to a Phoenix Coyotes
game and saw Alex gokin score that amazing goal
on former colleague Brian bue and he was hooked I
want to play hockey dad and here he is now amazing
Sacrifice by his mom and dad in order to get him
to where he needed to go to play and look at the
results that we're seeing now 40 goals already
this year again on Pace for 70 he needs some
blue ribbons to start dancing here in Toronto
to match his sweater went over and gave Sydney
Crosby a high five before the competition began
yeah looks like he's going to fall a little short
absolutely there is a time limit but when the NHL
kind of went through their experiments
no one really came close just goes to
show you what I know all my favorite
isn't currently in last place yes he
is our Emily Kaplan part of our coverage she's
down on the ice with Tom Wilson Emily Tom you
got to be a spectator tonight what are you
looking forward to most uh it's it's great
hanging with the guys uh we got a front row seat
here so uh it seems like a really fun event and
just hanging out with the guys have a couple
beers we got the night off so watch the guys
uh go Toe to Toe who do you think going to win
this all I honestly I was talking to a few people
about that there's so many so many great players
out there it's uh I don't know it might have to
take a couple side Wagers here and take a horse
but I think Connor's probably the favorite but
there could be some sleepers well if you wanted to
give $1 million to one of these guys who would you
give it to if I wanted to give a million dollar
to someone oh I don't know that's a tough one I
guess Nate maybe cuz he picked me last night in
the draft so we'll go with that awesome thanks Tom
and Jo few be thanks a lot I think he's already
had a couple uh barzel out there now from Conor
Bard righty to righty thought coming in M
that Matthew would be one of these guys who
would really want to try to win this title oh I
think every one of them wants to win obviously
but being at home in front of his home fans
and all that look at this is a lofty title to
be named the NHL's most skilled player there's
not a player in the league that wouldn't want
that title just 13 goals for Matthew this year
course those Islander fans are always screaming
shoot when he has the puck he loves to set
up his teammates and that cameraman almost
took that one off the teeth right there you
better get out of that corner I think he took
it off the ankle ouch so Matthew Barelle 16
points one better than Austin Matthews keeps
Austin in the seller and to your point even
if you don't win these events you still get
points by being second and third there
so every shot counts got a hit the net
though so our final participant is going to be
David poock 61 goals last year 33 goals this
year a one-time machine on the Bruins power play
got 11 Power Play Goals this year so he knows what
he must do 23 points to get the full Five Points
oh that hits the post shot number one two points
there you go there's the one he needed yeah he'll
take his time I think this is smart you can see
the the timing he has on his shots not only
velocity but just perfect perfect positioning
adjust to the puck there so when it's coming
to him he's hitting right between his legs big
four-pointer there he's got a chance three more
pucks he can take it hard to get it up from this
angle yeah 18 he's got a shot mess that's 21 here
he knows he needs this one he got [Applause] it
24 he gets McKinnon by a point well I was I
was batting 500 one for two David poock one
of the League's best Shooters shows off his skill
right [Applause] there clutch at the end from the
bad angle there he got him up high and so he gets
the full Five Points here's the big clutch shots
Mass late yeah this this is the toughest angle to
get it on fire too not only to get from the angle
but also CU you don't have a lot of room they're
pretty close to the net from there but he managed
on a one timer to get him up on one the event
because of it so Sydney Crosby and Connor Bard
has the two passers for us PK you guys ready I
got Conor badar down here Sydney Crosby okay Sid
this is your 10th All-Star game you know you see
a guy like this on the other side a guy that's
just starting his career wants to be exactly like
Sydney Crosby in every facet of it what's some
advice that you can give him being at his first
All-Star game all in I think uh great opportunity
to see the guys um you know meet guys see familiar
faces after you've been there a couple times and
uh just enjoy this this weekend with the fans and
uh with all the players amazing Connor I'm sure
it's got to be like uh Christmas morning for you
seeing Sydney and all these guys what's it like
being on the ice with all of these professionals
these guys that have done it at such a high level
for such a long time you're here now you're on
the biggest stage for hockey how does it feel
to be around these guys yeah it's great I mean
I think just growing up watching them and um you
know obviously Sid and all these guys looked up to
but uh in the end everyone's you know human being
and it's good to just get to know guys and uh kind
of build those relationships and and maybe learn a
little bit so it's fun well we got the future and
the present here now we take over yeah I got it
I'm here with David Pano out of Boston beown the
North End pasta what was your strategy in that
round uh honestly the first three uh I was trying
to take it easy it was kind of far it looks way
far than uh in a game but after the first shot I
kind of blacked out so I I honestly didn't even
know how many points I had until I came back
so well you had a lot ah thanks I honestly uh
just blacked out you know try to shoot and get in
the zone great job man keep up the best BCI back
up to you yeah David poso and Conor McDavid in a
good position we have breaking news they took two
points away from David Pasto maybe they just got
the wrong point total by sight and upon further
review it belongs to Nathan McKinnon now pasta
still gets three and a half because he was tied
with dry cidal so there's the current standings
two events down four to go will eliminate two
after six events the next competition is
the passing challenge here's how it works
our Allstars can do a lot more than just skate
and score they too shall pass as it's time for
the NHL passing challenge players will have
45 seconds to skate up and down the ice while
taking aim at clusters of targets set up
along the boards the smaller the target
the more points it's worth with chances to
earn one two or three points with each pass
after firing five passes as they travel
from crease to crease six more PS will be
waiting three in each end the player whose
passes earned the most points takes our top
spot so this is the most popular event of the
evening the passing challenge returns after
a 4year absence there's David Pasto he's not in
this competition talking to William neander who
is in this competition and as you can you see
Nathan McKinnon now with five points at plus
750 on our ESPN bet odds couple guys from Nova
scoa they'll be teammates mess in the All-Star
game tomorrow yep not a bad Duo right there
Crosby was McKinnon's first draft pick last
night in the players draft he grew up watching
Sydney Crosby and emulated a lot of his allight
work ethic and brought that to the rink each
and every day and one of the hardest working
players in the game as we know and the results are
because of it his results are because of it you so
righties will go first in the NHL All-Star
passing challenge attempting 11 passes all
on the forehand a possible 33 points so Nathan
McKinnon Banks five after we eliminate two all
these points still matter all the way through
the end of the night so every competition every
rep matters we don't erase and start over at any
point and McKinnon's probably he's he's still a
little confused that probably happened right
right the skills competition do I have this
right you want to make sure you have it right
there's a lot at stake here you don't want to
be out there going through the wrong drill or
the wrong target so they're really explaining
to him now so make sure he's fully aware of
what he's supposed to be doing and this is
a uh this is a highly skilled uh event right
here for every one of these players a mckin
have a monster year passing the puck this year
he's got 53 assists and here he goes [Applause]
passing on the move another two-pointer there
two nothing on that [Applause] one
he's got to get he wasn't sure what
to do there now he's to pass all the way
across the ice misses again so here we
go got to hurry up now clock is winding down
he's not going to get think oh he's got to go
rapid fire here he's going to get the buzzer
boom I don't think that last one's going to
count he didn't have one on a stick controversy
so for now 13 points for Nathan McKinnon again
a possible 33 what he was at a little bit of a
disadvantage going first here because he didn't
look like he knew exactly what was supposed to
be going on looked a little unsure of the uh the
sequence so again William neander also what do
I go first I'm sure the NHL sent these guys an
email with what to do and a video example my
guess they didn't open it you got put on the
bottom of the barrel so William nander goes
he was in the fastest skater competition he
accumulated one point for that Austin Matthews
is the only guy hasn't got a point get of course
it's early one it's a two-point from nander
he's flying another two so he you can see he
realized after the buzzer went off I got to
pick up the pace a little bit here get to my
next Puck there we go solid contact he looks a
little more sure what he's up to now now he's
to go all the way over with these this probably
will be the difference the guy who you know gets
three in a row here yep on the long one now
he's going to get on his horse to beat the
clock and he will lot of time he can take his
time obviously the smaller the target the more
points so neander finishing with
16 points that edges McKinnon
by three he's the current leader
as you can see nine more guys to
go so you're right mckinon was kind of
the guinea pig wasn't he going first I
think no one knew really what to do I think
the players have a much better understanding
of the pace they need to do it with now to
get their all the shots all the passes in
and I think they know exactly the route
that they have to take so k m it's a big
Advantage car up next I think these
players are better when they do it
a game speed they're used to doing at a game
speed instead of kind of taking a little bit
of a l Fair attempt at it the quicker they
play that's what their more natural instinct
is caros control there gets it back he
went for the big Target there missed
there we got that one got that one got that
one he's won a rookie of the year a Norris a
Smite a Stanley Cup a Hobie baker man what
a start kale Mark Carr is going he's going
for the big one ohes hockey player 14 points
H needs to beat neander 16 nice one nice one
we got a new leader oh three that's big well
done all the way up to 23 points neander with
the hockey clap kale Mar is our new leader
that was impressive down the stretch did he
get points for that that looked like it just gra
the edge I know I was like I'm looking like where
Matthew barzel is up next this guy loves the pass
certainly he'll be one of the favorites in this
competition I like Leon Dr settled in this
competition as well mhm one of the best passers
of now National Hockey League so here comes barzel
oh miss that swinging a Miss on pass number one
slower Pace here go he went for the big one and
nailed it and I think he went outside does he have
to stay inside the uh [Music] goes so now three
long passes only at nine points he's got to get
some big numbers here misses that one I don't want
to be a stickler on the rules guci but is he going
outside the Middle Lane there that he supposed
to stay in's a little he made the pass a little
shorter that little orange scrip down the middle
of the ice I think he was venturing out of that he
needs big numbers here he misses it yes last one
got it so not bad 21 points in second place two
behind ma barzal got four in the pass a skater oh
wait you're getting a little close to the Target
though trying to get a GPS for this competition M
we need to Old School Direction they brought the
paper take a ride to the second light find
the Denny's make the legal U-turn exactly
I don't know I don't think they did enough
preparation before this one this seems to
be a little confusing for the players but they've
had enough opportunity now to watch what needs to
be done I think we can put the paper away now
all I think so so JT Miller disappointing one
timer competition a half a point he's our first
Lefty to go starting at the other end obviously
lefties we mentioned righties go first the rest
will be left-handed they'll start the other end
cuz they don't want to move the targets just keep
in the same spot nice solid two-point start for
Miller misses that [Applause] one misses
that one picks up the puck of the blue line
good one there I have to say you got to take
into account the nerves for these guys that
are you know not used to being in these skills
competition at this level and seems to be a
little nervous to me yeah he's uh going for
the small Target missed all three only at
Five Points here with there is a little pressure
down there you know you don't you wouldn't think
about it but I remember doing the accuracy
shooting there going out and I can feel my
legs a little bit little little tremble little
little nervous absolutely [Music] absolutely
so JT Miller you sure voted in by the fans seven
points JT was just a little nervous uh you could
tell little hesitant up next Nikita kucherov we
talked about his monster season even better than
his MVP season an absolute future Hall of cam
what a career he's building John Cooper Raves
about his commitment so last year his season
ends and they lose to the Maple Leafs took
about a week off rented a rank in Tampa and
was on the ice every day yeah practicing and
it's showing this year he's really kind of got
a good opportunity to rest because it didn't go
deep into the playoffs but for me one of the for
me one of the I'm not sensing a lot of intensity
here m not quite not quite enough intensity
whatsoever here but I love the way he plays the
game he might he might have got into Tom Wilson's
cooler four points for COV this uh this is not a
good look quite frankly and the fans are booing
them and that's what happens when you don't try
your best and you're in a hockey City like
Toronto they're going to let you know yeah
that Fan's not too pleased with [Applause]
it not a great look for Nikita coer off there
he's uh just a five-point effort not sure what
was going through that mind wasn't really into
it from the start well that's his first event
that kind of takes him out of the running for
the million dollars I would have to think yeah
he can't afford a zilch right and uh now Quinn
Hughes you can't go through an event and not
get any points in order to expect to win this
it's amazed how this young fella mes continues to
just improve on his game he's a legit NH shelle
Superstar legit Norris Trophy candidate captain
of the Vancouver conuts well got thrust into a
leadership role as Captain of Vancouver conects
and is not baded ey his play has not diminished
because of it the weight of the captaincy has
not hurt him he's played unbelievable in fact
he's probably playing some of the best hockey of
his career and sometimes you know the pressure
of being a captain trying to do too much there
can weigh on a player but it hasn't affected him
one bit nobody loves hockey like the Hughes
Brothers man Mom and Dad are here for the
week like the Hugh Brothers but you're right you
get one son go to the NHL two three and they're
all superstars and they're all superstars
they're all amazing skaters there would it
be unbelievable all three of them on the team
Canada unreal right Team USA team us team yeah
watch your mouth Team USA would that be amazing
or they'll all be there I mean they're they're
that good and quinnon going to try to finish up
strong with a two can't quite get it so he's at
15 caror McDavid on deck US wouldn't borrow
wouldn't borrow the Hughes Brothers to the
Canada for this trade we we'll
trade you two Hugh Brothers for
McDavid so Conor McDavid who won the fastest
skater competition with five points did not take
part in the one- timer I expect uh I expect him
to do very well in this competition right here 23
points is the number to beat kale Mar there are
live standings he'll start off with a solid two
want to get some early see if he goes for two
here oh he went for little one he got it up to
Five Points see where he goes here goes little
again didn't get it D got that one he did miss
that he's going big see if he goes big across the
ice no no he missed the middle one now he gets the
middle one so here comes McDavid he'll arrive in
time to get all three of these off he's only got
10 better hit the big numbers misses it missed
the two oh H David only 10 I did not see that
coming BCI oh good news for Nathan McKinnon he
didn't want to get McDavid out too far in front
of him started out so good started off so good
you hear what I'm saying but it did not end well
Emily Kaplan with Brady kachuck the allstar yeah
and Brady you got two friends here we got Kesler
whose Grandpa was your dad's equipment manager and
Maverick whose dad is Rick uh taket the coach of
the kuu so tell me about these kids why you
enjoying it with them yeah well we know you
know got a history and kler and and you know the
Wilson family you know Shelly Stan's wife was my
babysitter growing up and and of course M with
uh you know talk talk and uh you know of course
my dad playing together so it's a lot of great
memories and and kind of go back to memory Lane
you keep watching Big Walter cross mod how do you
think he's enjoying this oh he's loving it he's
having a great time and uh know we had a great
time last night be able to you know share this
together and of course tonight tomorrow awesome
thanks Brady fell us yeah we talk about the Hughes
as one of those great American Hockey families
put like a Chucks right there Keith should be
in the hall of fame most career goals by a guy
who isn't in the Hall of Fame Matthew and Brady
full-fledged Superstars themselves Elias patteron
now nine points see what he does across the ice
goes for the big boy now he'll go middle to get
some points he'll go so he Ops to go two of the
middle ones M make sure I keep accumula up to
16 yeah you just got to get points you can't
get a puck here especially at this point of the
compe or the event there and not get any points
oh that was a good shot there better har very good
oh stumble fumble oh nice we have a new leader you
got to finish strong in this competition got
to finish strong those last six shots are key
that was impressive from Pon what a year he's
having in Vancouver he be paid handsomely for
it went for the little guy yeah and I tell you
what there something on the ice there you took
a little stumble there ice is slippery little
sniper nice and slippery in the 25-year old
swed 27 goals this year after 39 last year that
little stumble is going to hurt MC David in the
overall now I think could we'll see so Austin
Matthews failed to get a point in the one-timer
competition now he'll try the passing challenge
to accumulate some points he's got some room his
teammate William neander at 16 then the big boys
three of them over 20 barzal marar and Pon Here
Comes Matthews here where he starts he goes for
the big boy and gets it that's a three-pointer big
targets one the medium two the little three and
he's two for two with the three-pointer he when
I watch him play it looks like he was born with
a puck on his stick it is he looks so comfortable
out there and it's it's just oh four for four
with the little Target already up to 12 missed
that one missed that one another the long pass to
cross see if he trying to get some going to have
to hurry a little bit here oh that hurt thought he
there get the two I thought he might go two twos
there he's got to hurry a little up to 14 should
get all three off see if he can pass at least pass
his teammate there's a two he's up to 16 bam
so he jumps all the way up to 19 he's able to
pass Hughes and McKinnon and nander so he's
going to get these guaranteed points with only
one passer remaining hson Ma marzelle and Matthews
the current top four as you see right there five
points for first four for second three for third
two for fourth and one for fifth I think Leon Dr
for me is one of the best passers of national
hoey league it's hard to say if as a great goal
scorer he is but Absolut his passing is backhand
forehand elevated anywhere you can put the puck
anywhere he wants see how he does here we're going
to review Elias Patterson's last shot we're not
sure so we have to hold off the standings nothing
on that first one from trial this misses the three
there it'ss that
three-pointer nothing there got that one
now he's got to get hot he got to get hot
bam three-pointer oh boy not going to do it
no certainly looking good for Pon or marar
like I said they're reviewing Pon fam there's
a three just missed that one just missed that
one so disappointing 12 for Le on dry side
all yeah he W he was definitely disappointed
with that can see it look in his face there
he he was looking for better results yeah
well just think McDavid and dry Shadow
combin for 22 who would have who would
have ever that would have been third place if
you combin the two of them yeah so we want to
make sure this is official to make sure Elias
Patterson is your five-point winner [Music]
on So currently Matthew barzel is tied to the
top of the standage with seven he's with Kevin
weeks thanks so much appreciate that there bchi
up top in mess here with Matthew barzel the young
dazzling New York Islander take us through the
strategy how was it it was fun uh I missed my
first one got got a little nervous I was like
oh God so I turned it up and it's uh came out
with a decent run this looks tougher than it
actually people might give it credit for it
oh people don't understand like we could hit
the one all day but I mean that three is like
that's it's pretty small target shooting
cross ice so uh yeah I mean I I'd love to
see the average folk get out here and try it mes
made the point that this is even harder because
you're not doing it necessarily at game speed
especially you you're always playing at with
the afterburners on so well I think actually uh
if the targets were moving it might be a little
easier cuz guys are in motion you know during
a game so it's actually a little tougher when
it's standing still like that and we're moving so
kind of like a weird deception thing so I liked
it to be honest with it was fun sweet thanks so
much appreciate it back up to you Bui all right
six primary events so we're halfway through three
competitions remain they're still trying to find
out if Elias Pon beat the clock on his last shot
oh NHL Allstar Weekend begins first player chosen
COV we're going to have to go as Sydney Crosby I
think you do we got David pass that oh yeah get
over here that's a of Toronto we didn't want to
make him sweat too much we had to get him on our
team when it comes to picking hockey teams don't
ask the actor I thought I was in Blades of Glory
for most of the time that I was out there
then I realized holy I'm at the NHL allstar
game all right so Elias patteron looks like
he's going to get the full five you're supposed
to have the puck on your stick before it hits
zero you're allowed to finish the play mes but
did he touch this last Puck before the clock
ran I believe he did but this little uh trip
this little hiccup right there almost cost him
but I think he did get the puck on his stick
but by the time the clock turned to zero so Fi
we're not going to be sticklers for the clock
that are we or not there's a million dollars on
the line M1 millionar hardest shot competition
is next you see the current standing seven points
a piece for Pon and barzal the rules for hardest
shot slapshot not just one of the best hockey
movies of all time but the centerpiece of our
next competition the NHL hardest shot our
Allstars get two chances to fire the puck
Place 30 ft from the goal line as hard as they
can they can skate in from the nearest Blue Line
to gain momentum and the shot must be on goal
to be calculated if a stick breaks or radar
malfunctions another attempt will be awarded
the hardest shot of the night earns the most
points so simple pretty simple did you ever do
the hardest shot oh you kidding I I I couldn't
have broken a pain of glass with my shot first of
all I never took a slap shot that wooden Northland
what was your brand of stick with a wooden stick
back in the day Louisville you were a Louisville
guy well I first started with sherid but then I
then I used Louisville forever ni shs are the old
feather light they broke like kindling though that
was a problem and used to get penalties because
they would break there I couldn't believe the
referees were giving me penalty for cross check
in my stickle break Bo all right so hardest shot
as you can see here the we have eight participants
Elias P's a big favorite here M defending Champion
the only player in the competition tonight who's
won before and he's really one of the fewer guys
in the league who still uses the slap shot a lot
he kind of a Dying shot in the league and you
wouldn't think that he could shoot the puck as
hard because he doesn't look all that bulky but he
obviously he's got tremendous power and his timing
it's all about the timing right in this event
a lot of the power comes from your legs course
we no longer use the gun we use the uh obviously
the tracking the puck now exactly so here's Austin
Matthews and again he's not really a slap shot guy
per se as well well he shoots him pretty good off
the one time on a slap shot but but the hardest
shot we've seen from him all season is 991.43 in
a game well behind some of the big guns I think
the average fan would probably be surprised by
that he uses angles and he pulls the puck in and
positioning accur and positioning and knowing
that goalie awareness when you're when you're a g
that oh there he goes again 96 he got behind that
one game average that's very good again top speed
for him all year in a game is 991.43 he goes all
the way up to 9622 don't forget there this is
a lot stick related a lot of these guys don't
have really stiff sticks they use a lot of Whi in
their stick so they can get it off quicker without
is much power but in this competition you could
get you could get your manufacturer like bow to
give you a little stiffer stick to get more on we
we should get PK and and we down there're asking
if these guys change their Flex now M can bring
it oh boy he's not very he's not very far behind
Pon for top speed and highest average oh that's
going to be hard to beat 17 shots this year during
games with at least 90 mil hour that's the most
of anybody being a defenseman he's going to have
more Slap Shot opportunities every time I see him
he looks like he's getting bigger and stronger oh
yeah so 102 56 a nice lead as Matthews Falls to
Second David poast again more of a skilled
shooter like Austin Matthews how much power
can you know have when I talk about goalie
awareness is about when you when the pugs
com to you you see where the goalie is moving
from and you're shooting a back against the
grain or into corners and sometimes it's not
how hard you shoot as go where you shoot it
again we have to start talking about the line
as the competitions go on was pasta 9328 again
not quite the same power of a pson and my car
but that's what I'm saying that he could have
just as much power but the stick the shaft
on the stick is a different release point so
that has a big factor in this competition I
would be curious if any of these guys try to
stiff reflex for this yeah that was you could
tell he got that one more purely and it was
9527 you like going in a long drive contest
instead of using your regular size Shaft or
length shaft there you get another 3 or 4
Ines on it there as long as you can square
it up it's going to give you a lot more
momentum on the swing so so ma holds on to
his lead comfortably you see live standings
if he could take this competition he'd be
up to 11 again you want to make sure you make
the cup but also accumulation of these points
to get that $1 million prize Miller's got a
bomb Miller is a big strong kid [Music] mhm
I'll tell you one or two that's he's 1800th
of a second behind see if he can top that and
get in front of K Mar we'll have one more
chance to do it Miller oh didn't get that
one but a good effort from JT Miller currently
in second to kale marar as Elias Patterson we
mentioned this is the clear favorite highest Top
Shot speed of anybody in the group during games
this season defending Champion see if he can top
102.5 6 you think he can reach 103 misses he did
last time as defending champ 103.2 we'll see
I you know it's in him yeah I know we've seen
him do it before so it would be surprised
bam no didn't get that one one more shot
it's interesting this harder shot you got to
hit the ice behind the puck in order to load
that shaft okay and if you miss at it and
don't time it properly you're not going to
get the velocity as we saw there the 98 is not
what he normally would shoot this Puck at this
one will be better that was his first shot in
this competition under 100 in his young career
bam he didn't get that either you could tell just
you know sometimes you shank him right M time for
him that's a shank for you and I be shanking a
little more than the he is currently in third
with three Shooters to go all right our current
leader K Mar yeah he knew right away he he didn't
time up he's your winner so just five were in
this competition kale Mar takes the over all
lead PK suban yeah guys kale Mar here kale are you
surprised or did you expect to win this event oh
I didn't expect to win it I some of the boys told
me I should go in it so figured I'd never take a
running started a puck before so I might as well
try it rumor has it that you changed the flex on
your stick were you doing any uh fixing with
the stick before the event nothing before the
event I got a pretty stiff stick so I think that
gives me a little Advantage so and last question
you're so you're such a great skater you do it
all like how are you so good everybody wants to
know how are you such a great hockey player this
early in your career oh that's a loaded question
I'm not good enough to beat McDavid today
though so um yeah I don't know about that
we'll take that win and we'll move on well not
too many are good job K Mar hardest shot in the
world right [Applause] now yeah he can bring
in he should have been confident going into
that competition the the NHL tracking info data
has showed us that so Mar is your winner Miller
Pon Matthews three poock and there are the live
standings Mar has a one-point lead over Patterson
as we prepare for competition number five of
six in round one so a cut line is coming two
Fells are going to go home with two competitions
left Canada a fact eh with Will Arnette Maple Leaf
Gardens home of 11 times Stanley Cup champions
and the first NHL allstar game is now a grocery
store Center ice is on aisle 25 by the tuna the
only leaves here are Iceberg and [Music] kale Irv
there's a cleanup in aisle 25 as we welcome you
back to Toronto the All-Star skills competition
here's your updated standings look it wouldn't
be a shock of any of these guys finished up top
little surprised about Nikita kucherov at the
bottom there but right now marar pon barzal
have the top three spots locked up and we got
lots more coming straight ahead we are through
four events and still have four events to go we
got the stick handling then we got the uh Cheetos
accuracy shooting can a brother get a goalie
yes and the players should be able to choose the
goenda Obstacle of course two more events then
four players will get cut and we'll move on win
or take all for 1 million big ones here's Ray
Ferraro I'm Steve Levy so my takeaway is if
you're an alien and you just landed down here in
the planet you say that kic David is's a terrible
passer okay that passing that passing challenge
was complicated and very diff difficult I thought
well I've been in the skills thing I've done
the the puck handling one and you got to follow
along it makes it so hard and I thought it was
pretty interesting some guys passed it really
slow that didn't seem to work some guys passed it
really hard that sort of kind of work but that the
passing one for me was the most fun I I really
lik that barzel made an interesting point he
said if if you're used to passing to a moving
Target yeah that a stationary Target and it's
really small right the targets and that was other
takeway it it looks harder than it actually is cuz
you're watching at home my buddies are texting
me how how can you miss it I'm telling you that
three-point Target is Tiny because it it's not
you're moving at a certain Pace the target's
getting smaller as you move it it's hard man time
now for stick handling this won't be easy here are
the rules the shortest distance between two points
is typically a straight line but tonight our allar
Stars will show off their silky stick work as
they Zig and zag in the upper deck NHL stick
handling competition each player will take a turn
down the ice controlling the puck around objects
in their way while going forwards and backwards
as they approach the goal they'll have to show
off some tow drag swag firing a puck on net to
stop the clock fastest time takes home the most
points John Butcher Goos Mark Messier back with
you nine players will participate in the stick
handling competition so there is a backward
skating aspect to this mess and we just have
the one defenseman you got think that's got
to be an advantage for Quinn Hughes no doubt
it's an advantage for Quinn Hughes but all these
guys are going to be able to handle that not a
problem but obviously Quinn Hugh is practicing
and doing that much more than the fors during
the game obviously practicing it much more
but we'll see he's a he's a dynamic skater
hockey player and uh these guys have done this
drill many many times in their career now that
wide trip through the lighted targets now
here he goes this is where his backwards
get he maybe can help him you have to keep
control the puck you can't toss it around
the target there it is beautiful transition
you have to finish with the puck in the net
oh yeah all right excellent we just don't know
for sure until we see players go what's a good
score yeah but he got he didn't lose the puck
he was clean through it yep so Quinn Hughes
just over 29 seconds eight participants
to go here's the initial yeah look at the
edging and this is one of the competitions
this is a good beautiful little kind of a
tow grab maneuver to finish and you have to
finish caror McDavid a lot of his summer work
is doing this drill right here so this
could be an advantage for him because
this is what he trains on this is one of
his suggestions to the NHL when the two
sides got together to try to make this
skills competition a little better for
the fans create some drama some nervousness
maybe for the players cuz they're playing for
1 million bucks no one does this better
than look look at the speed he does it
with now he's going to wheel quickly oh little
stumble on the edge there you see the you can
see the transition is not quite as smooth as as
as a defenseman right but still not too bad K Mar
would do this one as well try he's he's going to
beat Hughes oh my goodness [Applause] unbelievable
the acceleration is just insane he is clearly
taking this seriously oh he does everything he
wants to win this I more than anybody out there I
believe there's a little stumble on the left skate
[Applause] there and then just make
sure you get the job done there and
finish so now Hillway Elias Patterson he's
currently in second place overall with 10
points so he's certainly among those a favored
to win it as each competition comes gets harder
and harder now points will be doubled later so
you can come from behind if a leader stumbles
and you win an event here comes P wants to
be clean initially and then here we come down
Runway number five yeah that's Beau Long Reach
can help now you got to show some acceleration
mess and he does get get to the turn nicely
very good oh and that's pretty much do it for
him that hurt re-engage the target oh he's
got to be disappointed he would have had an
outstanding timeing chance at it two still
wants to finish strong cuz you never never
know he could finish Fifth and get a point
and one point could be the difference for
$1 million in I do not believe he'll get
any points out of this which is going to
really hurt his chances but who knows as you say
just barely over Hughes but yeah he was cooking
good that's too bad yeah see it just that
just gave R out on yep lost the edge side
of the boot oh he's got to be disappointed
all right here's our boy Nikita let's see
let's let's focus on the int let's go
buddy let's go 25755 the time to beat
okay clean through there here we go now
we got a Sprint here Nikita this is a
oh he's going to finish where
he will left off there we
go [Applause] not quite the McDavid
intensity he's hearing it from
the fans again this is what the
NHL wanted to avoid when they offered
$1 million to to the winner but you
know the keeto makes 9.5 a year and
there's a nice little wave to the
crowd clearly not his [Applause] Jam I
don't think mcdavid's real happy about
it either so con McDavid Remains The
Leader teammate Leon dry Sidle will be
next I don't know if uh Dr title's blad's going to
fit between the pucks here on this he's got some
big boots and a big bow or look at that thing yeah
he definitely got the biggest blade in the league
accuracy shoot shooting will be uh the sixth and
final competition of round one then four players
will be let go to become Spectators or to join
Tom Wilson see how the big Leon can backwards
get a couple stries look like he I don't if he
really let's see that was better he not going to
catch McDavid okay he puts it in but but clearly
Hughes got through the backward skating seemed to
be much Clear cleaner than the uh than the forward
no doubt about it second place for Leon dry sadle
behind his teammate just in front of Quinn Hughes
who remains in third you can just see the speed
that McDavid plays with it and not only the speed
that he plays with but but under control with the
with the skill that's a good transition there he
kept his feet moving that's what you need to do
you got to keep the speed up and the way to do
that is to keep your feet moving all right Nate
Dog this guy certainly is going to give it his all
he can fly does everything fast super competitive
plays a lot of power very quick hands nice clean
pretty good through here pretty good through here
now see him yeah he quieted his hands down there
he's a real uh choppy stick Handler just can't
AFF o almost lost the puck on the gate he's going
the fans can sense it oh little stumble there just
saves it oh sideways skating there he comes he's
got a chance to catch McDavid going to be close
no no didn't quite get it fully clean throughout
the competition he does as quick as he is yeah he
in second place and he's put positioning himself
well but absolutely came in with five points but
as quick as as much power that McKinnon plays
with and as much skill as he has you can see
the difference of mdav the way that he can get
through the the pucks there with speed accelerate
into the backward some forward skating and then
finish it off on the acceleration there 2 seconds
and this it's it's a lot of feet if you're just
if you're judging it by feet not seconds right
David P of course these Toronto fans don't like
Boston [Music] Bruins yeah that's they're going
to boo PA announcer said let's let them hear
it okay that's Boston pasta pretty clean let's
see how he does here transitioning pretty smooth
there round gate one who wheelie here we go this
is proven to be a little more difficult this
backwards scanning from the forward than we
anticipated pasta is not going to catch McDavid
oh oh no don't do that pasta [Applause] no
oh Bak came in with four and a half he still
beat coocher off Believe it or I'm not sure if
was doing this competition I'd be that non schwant
on anything for a million dollars right his pasta
certainly was in a position oh just fell off his
stick and he knew he had to go get [Laughter]
it one of the best faces in the NHL great
interview with Steve Levy and Ray Ferrar
on Sports Center before we went on the air K MS
said if he wins the 1 million he'll give all his
defenseman 100 Grand each they asked pasta would
he give Brad Marron any money he said not a penny
that was earlier on Sports Center great player
and a great interview all right Matthew barzal
should be good in this competition he can stick
handle and he can skate yeah tremendous skater
little problem through the first line of Lights
this is smooth very good transition there we
go pretty good time this is going to be right
around the top three I think if yeah so can't
quick all right so he's second now he beats
McKinnon it's Conor McDavid hanging on with
one player left William neander good effort
by barzel though another four points could be
coming his way he has seven now look Williams
got great hands and I just don't see him
being able to beat that 25 to so there's
our live scoring MCH currently barzel is
tied for the lead with Mard McDavid tied
with Pon with 10 so William nanders could
affect these standings if he can get in the
top five he should he can stick handle with
the best of them oh and there's your answer
that hurt and I don't think he finished those
[__] either I'm not sure if he did either he
knew he had to do it all he had knew he had to
go full Full Speed Ahead but just couldn't keep
quite keep it under control so McDavid will
be fine at one barzel is going to be fine at
two here he comes pretty good finish really oh the
late stumble is going to cost him a second or two
in the end 27.2 and somehow finish third have
to go back a video replay on those [__] down
here to begin with but that's the thing about M
keep getting back to it the thing about McDavid
there everybody's trying to hustle up and do this
as fast as they can but he's able to do it under
control M neander did pour it on late and then he
really got down the ice quickly PK suban is with
David posn he's on the cut line PK is he nervous
I'm here with one of the best dressed guys in the
NHL pasta listen you're in seventh place right now
you know how this thing is top eight move on you
know what's your game plan to get some more points
you're right on the brink of being eliminated and
tell us walk us through what happened when you
missed that open net you don't miss too many
of those uh it was just a toin you know I have a
tough time with toins not used to those you know
well I like to work for my goals too I understand
soon as the goal is there now well I don't know
honestly uh you know just took a shot I didn't
missed it you know uh went to get my own rebound
and got it in sometimes it's just too good to
be true yeah that's right you guys heard it from
pasta he's got to get things going I think he will
I don't know the only accuracy shooting remains
Conor McDavid wins the stick handling and Allstar
skills presented by Draft Kings sports book The
goali is to be part of one competition tonight
and they can win themselves $100,000 as they
help all these other players win a million Kevin
weeks with the [Music] tenders all right B thanks
so much I'm actually getting an invite B you're
always talking about college hockey so I got a
college hockey stud here from University of Maine
black bear and also Boston Bruins so keep up with
the Bear theme what does it mean to be an allar
uh it's pretty special and uh I think you know you
just hearing you talk about college in Alaska it's
uh an honor to represent those those places I've
been I definitely wouldn't be here without them
and uh really excited to be a part of this group
and looking left and right week see it's uh pretty
surreal seeing the names and incredible talent in
this locker room so pretty excited about it well
you've earned the right you got some new pillows
huh yeah yeah first time uh had the All-Star
pillows so I'm excited to use them hopefully
mark them up a little bit that boy if not just
use the gloves like I told you off camera best
of luck thanks so much week appreci app thank you
all right we're heading over to cam talot now of
the LA Kings he's in involved in the conversation
he's got his two kids here going to see if we can
get talbo momentarily and there he is and there he
is talbo got you live on ESPN here congrats thank
you let's speak a little bit about your alma mater
if you will your college hockey Alabama Hansville
you like that one huh I love that one the the
original I love that story hey look you're from
nearby here about an hour and change family and
friends what does it mean to you who's here who's
special what do you got of course your kids are
here but who else is here yeah obviously that's
the most special part for right there that are
in the locker room running around having fun with
the boys so that makes me the happiest right
there but uh mom dad stepmom stepdad uh wife
obviously my uh brother-in-law from Dallas bunch
of buddies uh flew up drove up from all over the
place uh guys came in from uh calonia today took
the uh my dad drove him in for lunch and stuff
like that so uh there's a pretty good crew here
for the Tela Clan so I'm happy to have them all
here and uh it's just been a great weekend so far
love it happy for you congrats thank you tto Sarah
nurse former NHL and Toronto police great Steve
Thomas two-time Olympic medalist
and forward for pwl ter Tonto Blair
Turnbull and Cy Trophy winner and former
captain of your Toronto Maple Lea Doug
Gilmore accuracy shooting our final
competition of the first six of the
evening four players will go home after
this this is also a timed event a four
for five could beat a four for four
if the four for four guy goes a little
slow he a cucher out hit the first two he
thought he hit that one no now we blow the
whistle here the
stoppage only the I was just going to say I think
he wants new targets what do we do are we going to
start over I'm not sure what's going on here but
uh he didn't like something or hit something and
they didn't count it or yeah I got the feeling
we're going to start again he's having quite a
night for himself the Cheetos accuracy shooting we
got to get the Cheetos logos in there come on we
got to get the check get the Lays a classic
event Mark fessier won it twice in 1991 and
1996 you went four for four but again here you
got to go quickly too cuz a four for five can
beat a four for four all these Sharp Shooters
certainly I felt I felt better doing things
at game speed to be honest with you I I don't
wanted to shoot the puck hard I want the passes
to come like in game speed it just felt more
natural than trying to coo is obliterating the
[Applause] targets there you go yeah he cooch
is going to have an early exit tonight as he
goes over to talk and get a glove tap from
Maple Leaf Legend douge Gilmore Sarah nurse
and Blair turnbo also helping out the passing
tonight so the other end it's nurse and Steve
Thomas former mapel Lea what a great career Steve
Thomas had sure did played for 20 years scored
421 goals former teammate of Ray Ferraro played
for Chicago tono the Islanders the Devils Mighty
Ducks of Anaheim and finished up with Detroit
at the age of 40 he'll be passing to kale Mar
so Mar is our leader one for one two for two oh
H the post three for four Miss Miss got to get
this one oh oh that's too bad he did exactly what
I done myself to get the bottom targets to easier
one I think he did too yeah yeah
he did so you see little little
little piece of that Cheeto right
there just a little dust on the
fingers so Mar's time will likely change but
they'll get that official as we continue on
we mentioned 10 players wasp Here Comes
onto McDavid take the lower targets first
that's oh that's the Mark Messier
advice they're the easier targets to
hit get a little rhythm going get a little
confidence BCI all right you know it's like
making that first six foter six footer right
like don't practice those long putts for a
round just go with the two Footers hear that
sound sorry RoR McDavid led the league in
goals last year with 64 got 20 this year
not quite scoring at the same [Music] clip
Quinn Hughes warming up at the other end on
Deck just taking passes so now Mar's time is
[Music]
19.06.13 have to really pour it on McDavid
wants to continue getting points he wants
the overall Championship one for one two for two
three for three can he do it yes oh tremendous
oh and quick and you see the the way he shot it
with his velocity 9158 the new [Applause] leader
all right M you said go low first he actually
went in order he did he went around the clock
around the world B really like the way he
attacked the target so remember he already
has two first tonight that's one of the tie
Breakers later is how many firsts you get if
you're tied with a guy in total points so he
talks to kale Mar there live scoring if this
holds for McDavid he would be our new leader
Quinn Hughes now defenseman have won this in
the past Thomas cavet Ray Bor Jacob slaven and
of course yes Ray Bor nobody better than in
this [Applause] competition Bor won seven
times here comes Hues oh wow oh that's a
Miss there we go excellent Mory won seven
times seven times winner [Applause] wow
for a second we got a whopping $55,000 for
those whopping 5,000 five grand to win an
event 1 million tonight mess back back down
a bit for the weekend again four guys will be
eliminated after this event we'll be down to
eight players competing for a million dollars
here comes JT Miller we mentioned how accurate
of a shooter he is in actual NHL games can he
get himself a big point total he's right around
the cut line he'll need a four for four here or
maybe a four for five could be okay he's got
a chance needs these last two post there he
goes pretty good speed there really good y 13.5
87 as he'll take a couple fist bumps from Blair
Turnbull and thugy Gilmore on to McDavid Remains
the leader of the accuracy shooting got to let
your instincts take over in these bchi a lot of
times you see them just kind of throwing it at
the Target not doing it like you do it at game
speed or game intensity and if you do it at game
speed and game intensity your instincts take over
you're not thinking so much seem to be the players
that actually have the most success when they
do it that way pasta needs a big point total he
has four and a half right on the cut line he's
got hope he's won this event in 2019 he's the
only one participating who's one in the pack o
he misses the first surprising and the second
CR loves it turn them On's
going to go home early I'm
afraid yeah he just got off to a rough start
yep missed his first four finished it makes
such a huge difference if you hit that first
Target it it just relaxes you gets you in a
bit of a rhythm otherwise the soul out of body
exactly you can see it from body language hear
from the crowd too as they go a little more
anxiety so pasta will miss the cut go baby
and the prize for $1 million here's Nathan
McKinnon boys good as the goalies take the
ice now cuz they can do a little warm up here
because they're in the next competition see
McKennon he only knows one speed so he's
going to do this at game speed get it and
rip it I can guarantee you that taking
passes from Gilmore and player turnbo
Kon has a second and a fifth so
far seven points if he wants the
overall title he needs a good
number in this one not a good
start good Pace okay so McKinnon who came
in with seven points 15.9 [Applause] 58
he's fourth McDavid still the only sub 10 by a
strong number it's like Tiger Woods at the US
Open at Pebble Beach yeah William neanders up
now Willie styles again he's at Five Points he
needs a yeah he needs a quick yeah he does
that put him in good position if you can
get out here clean dry Ido and Matthews
are still to come they also both need a
[Applause] win slow start all a stumble
give me Puck snap that one so Soul star
good finish [Applause] yep so he's in a
position for third good effort by neander
who came in with five in this competition
he needs the those three points going two to
go Austin Matthews will go last in this accuracy
shooting at home as Leon dry Sidle warming up
taking a pass from Doug [Music] Gilmore certainly
a guy you can see rip off for in a r mess yes no
question got to get that first one probably kills
you with confidence I it does now you may start
to panic a little now now you're under now you're
under and0 for four yep now you're now you're just
flat out ped right yeah I think you got that one
all right now he'll settle down oh maybe not now
I just want to go home it's like when you shoot 51
in the front Miss right you just want to go home
Nine and Nine and this is this is so cruel like
players should be able to just walk off at this
point w I'd like to see him kind of torturing me
[Applause] yeah there he goes yeah fist pump from
Leon a lot of young boys and girls out
there watching these guys you got to you
got to finish it out that's right never
quit no matter what happens you a lot
of lessons so Austin Matthews remains
mess certainly this would be a another
guy so he really needs to beat McKinnon's
15.9 to advance he needs a point or Austin
Matthews could go home early well this is his
Forte right here shooting the puck Nobody Does
it [Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause] Better
so Hughes 14.8 is his number otherwise we got a
tiebreaker so four he needs to get under 14.8 and
change let see if he gets that first one and gets
some confidence and some Mo here we go needs
that first one got it got it oh looking go four
for five and with a good time it's going to be a
good time it's a good time excellent he's going
to make it Austin Matthews comes through second
place four points for him five for McDavid McDavid
wins another competition the skills competition
he helped to reimagine and recreate he's coming
through as Matthews is relieved Miller third
neander fourth yeah he was locked in there you can
tell he was locked in there it's an all Canadian
win there for the top five PK suban with Austin
Matthews yes I am here with the star of the night
star of the weekend and he is representing for the
six and for the city of Toronto awestin Matthews
how does it feel to now be the best shooter in
the world I need to make up some ground there so
I'm happy I could I want to keep this thing going
some ground you did make up some ground but how
great is it to be able to have that feeling you
know what I mean everybody Standing Ovation how
does that feel yeah it's amazing I mean I feel
like I've talked about it a little bit this week
and been fortunate to play some All-Star games and
um you know I always find the hometown guys I mean
they get so much love and support as they should
so uh it's been a great week so far and it's you
know it's been a great turn out here in Toronto
it's it's really been really special it's got to
be special too doing it with your teammates you
got Willie here beside you what do you think of
his performance so far been great he's been great
I mean uh you know we don't call Willie styles
for nothing man he's uh he's a treat to be around
and uh special person special player well as a
Toronto native I'm very proud of you and how you
represented the city Toronto I know you are thanks
guys Austin Matthews greatest shooter in the world
and he he's moving on PK one a performance he had
to come through and in the end Matthews gets it
done bam and but four guys are going home now they
have missed the cut two events to go goalies will
be part of our next competition you can tell he
wanted that he wanted to move on so our current
standings you can see David poock Leon dry
cidal Quinn Hughes and Nikita kucherov fail
to advance it's a one-on-one this is where the
goalies are involved they can win a 100 Grand
with the most saves as the as many shots as you
want one-on-one event is coming up hustle pays
off first five pucks worth a point shots under
the hash mark only most saves gets goalies 100
Grand if there's a tie save percentage is the
tiebreaker two more players will be eliminated
playing for the 1 million after the one-on-one
timed event and then we'll have the obstacle
course where points are doubled and that's
where you really can make a move and now the
the goalies get to play for some cash well
the goalies come in here in a little tough
spot too they got to get a little chance to get
warmed up which I think they're doing but they're
going to be facing some pretty good Shooters
right out of the bat and I'm glad that they'
decided that there's $100,000 for the goalies to
win otherwise they're just out here participating
right they can't play hockey without a scoreboard
referees and goalies they're all important Canada
fact with Will Arnett Nathan Phillips Square
named for the former Toronto mayor is skated
on by millions including our current mayor who
spends her lunchtime Wheeling around the square
dreaming of being Tess of virtue or tyomi depends
on the day eh welcome back to Toronto John Butcher
Mark Messier Steve Ley and Ray Ferraro are here
PK suban Kevin weeks Emily Kaplan so the goalies
will be part of our second to last event let's
recap Conor McDavid got things off he won the
fastest skater competition McDavid has been in
four competition so far he's one three and got
nothing in one Nathan McKinnon is in a position
but he's got to really pick it up in these last
two he just has seven points so far he barely
made over the cut line Elias Patterson sits at
10 passing drill he looked really good
in the hardest shot kale marar was your
winner he also got a second in the passing
challenge he is tied for second with Matthew
barzel again mat we mentioned McDavid
he's won three competitions just he does
everything so so quick so much finesse so
controlled he's just one of those players
just has the ability to focus and execute
what matters most he's doing this like a
game seven he know he wants to win and his
performance some so far as indicative got a
nice lead for $1 million all right the rules
for this next event the one-on-one here it
is now that we've Whitted the field down to
eight it's time to let our All-Star goalies
have some fun in the Honda one-on-one the skater
that sits in last place will go first selecting
the goalie they want to face as long as that net
minder isn't a teammate we'll put 60 seconds on
the clock and set pucks out in designated
areas on the ice the first five are worth
one point and the rest are worth two players
must carry the puck of until they cross the
hash marks before firing on net and they cannot
score off a rebound if a player is carrying the
puck when the clock hits zero we'll let them
take that final shot the highest total takes
the top spot and the Five Points wasn't it
for the goalies stop the most pucks take home
$100,000 it's time for the
NHL Allstar oneon-one let's
meet the All-Star goalies is participating in this
event from the Florida Panthers Sergey
bosski from the Vancouver Canucks pater Demco from
the Colorado Avalanche Alexander gorev from the
Winnipeg Jets Hunter Helu from the Dallas Stars
Jake uttinger from the New York Rangers eigor
shesterkin from the Boston Bruins Jeremy
Swan and from the Los Angeles Kings cam
talit now please welcome Sports Net's David Amber
and ESPN's Kevin weeks right we're down to our
final eight competitors and of course the goalies
are here as well and we're going in reverse order
and we have William neander you're eighth in the
standings but you can make up a lot of ground
we're going to have you pick your goalie so who
do you like you've been thinking about it I'm
just going to go with Cam talot he's standing
right in front of me so I think that's what
I'm picking you said you said cam talit you're
staring him down all right why cam talet because
he was standing right in front of me so I just
felt like that was a good choice all right all
right the the local boy cam Talbot's ready to take
the net against William nander good [Applause]
luck so William nander tied with Nathan McKinnon
just over the cut line with
seven points he'll need a big
event a timed event as many shots as you want
hustle pays off at the Puck is on the player
stick before the clock hit zero the play is
allowed to be finished two more guys get cut
after this [Applause] event and in the end the
goalies who are helping out this competition
the one who makes the most saves wins $100,000
does not count against a salary cap Miss dander
oh and hustle pays off first five pucks are
worth a point shots under the hash marks only
H to get that one two more pucks for neander
he's moving well oh big straight by tber he's
going to have a new coach when he goes back
to work oh Beautiful Finish there by neander
got three points so far these pucks are worth
two points and he going to go all the way back
to the blue line to pick them up as many
shots as you want 30 seconds left oh man
Talbot looks good I can see where fatigue
is going to come into a little bit of play
here absolutely [Music] [Applause] this another
save by S it's tough to score against these NHL
goalies the legs
are beautiful shot 911 save percentage for
talet now naner can finish this as the clock
runs out oh oh in honor of Peter for Berg he
ends with the postage stamp Olympic gol and
he is gassed that's a good drill that's a good
drill we're going to incorporate that into the
practice session yeah M squirts peew everyone
good for cardio good for skating there's the
first one mess yeah just at the skque he got a
couple through the legs thought a little opening
there yeah straight through the legs
that was a good shot there oh look at
this final move the first of eight oneon-one
shootout skaters here at ice level with Nate
the Great Nate Dog Nate McKinnon Nate I'm not
sure who you're looking for here but I got a
sense it's Sergey bosi you good with that
yeah he's one of the best ever so uh I'll
try my luck here see what I can do all right
Serge rasa to Florida panther you're up Bobs
so again that's the interesting part of this
competition the players pick their goalies
and Nate McKinna will go against the acrobatic
Sergey bosi I mean just look at the lineup of
the goalies who you can look over there and
say there's a weak point out there every one
of them incredible 911 sa Wily neander I'll just
take the guy sitting me I like that 35-year-old
Sergey bosi 621 188 the russan strong against
Nathan McKinnon early again McKinnon he needs
a strong effort here if he's going to win the
overall legs up oh beautiful move [Applause]
there he tried to shoot before he got
set easy to forget that barosi broke in with
the Philadelphia Flyers all the way back in
2010 Columbus some great years under John
torella Bez than on the Florida with that
big contract well he just caught fire at
the right time last year and he brought
him all the way to the Stanley Cup Final it
was incredible to watch his perform seemed to
get better with each game more confidence and
the team rolled that confidence right into the
finals so Nate McKinnon's in trouble [Music]
here he may not advance to the obstacle course
in the final round he's going so good job by
Sergey bosi having nice year 23 and 10 for the
[Applause] Panthers this one goes between the
legs here but after that it was it was all
Sergey that's a beautiful backand there for
McKinnon look at that angle for us there
you look there's nowhere where where you
going to shoot all right [Applause]
you can't take your teammate Batcher
dempo so who you do want to select to go
one-on-one with uh I'm going to have to
go with sway yeah why why sway uh
I can't score on any other guys on
breakaways I love it all right go for it
good luck American on American yeah you
can't pick your teammate so it's
JT Miller against Jeremy swayman
don't forget the goalies most safe gets
$100,000 so Serge barosi is off to a good
start there Jeremy Swan see how he does
that an outstanding year for the Boston
Bruins 924 save percentage second only
to Aiden Hill it's an easy first save on
[Applause]
Miller oh there's a beautiful move
really good and these are it looked
like San had him shut down there and
he still found it these are onepoint
pucks two through the legs so he gets two of
the five onepoint pucks now he gets as many
as he wants here legs getting heavy that
this point bchi oh that one came out the
stick funny I think he tried a little change
up yeah a little knuckle ball little knuckle
yeah oh sweet oh that was nice swingan thought
for sure he was going back to the forehand try
that moving in maybe oh oh bar and in I think
it was in the first time actually then hit
swan in the back and went in twice oh he not
going to score from there he tried to get it
before he got set but no way six points
did he take yeah that would have counted
he did touch the puck before the clock hit
zero so six points for Miller puts him in
second
so bosski had eight saves he's
the current go tender leader for
[Applause] $100,000 yeah he beautiful
Moon by Miller all right what goalie
next will be selected to go against Austin
Matthews who will Matthews pick all right
we've got Hometown boy Austin Matthews the
NHL leader and goal scored let's hear you
fans yeah now you're back GTA now you're
back all right Max who you going with
I'm going to go with thater dco ooh the big
man from Van all right well he's a teammate
tomorrow so maybe this is uh part of the
bonding get to know each other a little
better yeah or did you take AER that was
a long night Miss A of tall goalies down
there but that that Demco big boy he is a
big boy here comes Matthews he needs a big
goal total here eight points oh my that was
sick beautiful the coolest go of the night so
far try to get him before he got set again
aats or Matts as his friends call him job
by Demco Demo's mom and wife right here is new
baby new new Christian daddy so he saved four
the first five oh man that was sweet Matthews
has 26 seconds to go as many as he wants well
you're right coming on a big pass Tempco You
Don't See Much next you don't see anything
watching on the on the camera angle here there's
oh was that sick up to five for Matthews needs
these last two oh there's one oh that was really
nice through back he's not going to have time for
two this will be his last [Applause] Puck oh
he couldn't get had to get it up top he had
him beat he couldn't get it up top that would
have tied him with knee Lander instead he's at
seven but some real nasty stuff from Austin
Matthews yeah he really had a Dem Co guessing
on that 920 sa percentage for D go this year for
Vancouver why they're a big favorite coming out
of the West after getting Elias lolm they're not
done either they may make it one more move in
Vancouver all right Elias Patterson is up what
goenda Alias four goalies to choose from
two of them are vzna winners there's no
easy decisions here who are you going to go
one-on-one with uh going Jake Ginger Jake
oner why why Jake uh we were at dinner last
night and yeah a little friendly Shar so the
side who pays the bill good luck good stuff I
like that Jake AER former bu Terrier Terriers
were winners tonight six to three over New
Hampshire so Pon all kinds of talent he's got
reach he's got a shot mess certainly a guy you
could see he's trying to top knee Landers nine
it's a hockey player he's got an incredible
skill set and he's getting bigger stronger
as the years go go on here and seems really
maturing into a superstar in this [Applause]
league three straight saves there's
a nice one for Pon got 27 goals for
Vancouver last year of course2 points 39
goals really burst onto the scene still
needs a contract he's going to get a big one
I think the biggest thing for him this year
guci is his uh his consistency that he
played with 64 points in 49 games that's
Beauty so he's only got 19 seconds
left basically takes about 7even eight
seconds to get a puck and then get
the next one so he's got to hurry this
will be his last shot yep here here he
goes
oh the ler look very solid there BCI you look
good the post is your friend if you're net
minder is it ever so ainger stopped eight
of 10 s with bosski shooting percentage
is the first tiebreaker and you can see
right there in that goal there he he let
the golender make the first move and then
you have got your choices after that Matthew
barzel a lot of Islander fans are certainly
watching and a lot of your family are back in
Vancouver in that area who you picking here
I'm going to pick my New York counterpart
eagor Sherin wow I like it smart little
rivalry rival what we got New York all right New
York New York Big City of Dreams yeah Matthew
barzel just gets it that's what you do here give
us a moment his all those Islander fans back on
the island I'll be there this Thursday with yous
calling their game against the lightning on the
ESPN that'll be fun BCI that's a lot of fun you
me and PK for The Islander Lightning game on
the on the big Network ESPN so Matthew barzel was
Islander fans watching back on the island Belmore
wants to see their guy beat the
ranger save by
shurkin so tight oh that was a good shot got him
leaning there over the glove marzel's going he
wants to get to that second level to get as many
shots as he will he will have oh that's a heart
one 37 seconds now to go a tough year for Rashia
sturken best 899 save percentage maybe this would
give him some confidence well he got hurt and came
back and hasn't quite found his form but uh I have
no doubt no doubt that he will find it by the end
of the year and it's going to be a big influence
on the Rangers second half here oh beautiful still
doesn't have a shut out yet he's too too good a
goalie not to bring it back probably the first
time he's really been injured too and coming back
off and iny is you know takes a little bit of
experience last fck for barza I think unless he
can get back there in 3 seconds I don't think he's
going to make it got got it this will count it's a
big one oh in the post oh my [Applause] goodness
he's an entertaining player he likes to put on a
show great guy to talk to as well Matthew
Barelle fourth place oh man that's that's
a beautiful oh here to the legs and
it is just oh oh the top of the left
Pad but then hit the top of the right
pad and didn't Bank into the net like
you thought it might so eigor to St eor
they're on that too he H and N it's in
the kale Mar's up next what goalie will he pick
uh to be honest with you I don't I don't even
know I don't I don't I don't know if I have
a chance here so it's uh we're we're going
to try and put Pucks in the back of the net and
uh make the fans happy all right well good luck
don't give up and Conor McDavid of course will
be against Alex gorv Conor all right to score
as many goals as I can it's going to be tough
he's a great goenda gotcha all right little
Hockey East flavor here you Mass Minutemen UMass
low against [Music] heluk so right now uh bosski
and ainger are tied eight saves each with 80% save
percentage which is the tiebreaker if it ends this
way and they're still the leaders they'll split
the hund okay that's fair I like that there goes
the car now oh my goodness just a bit outside
taking a Long Way Around the Net taking a long
way oh there some power lethal oh number two so
he's building points early on the onep pointers
[Applause] see oh try the forber 34 seconds
left what you can hear blad cutting the ice
from up here on the edges what a skater what
a skater and the power that he skates with
oh that's nice oh he's fell down get back
up kale R has time for two par 83 I got I
okay nope hurry they'll get they'll get get
more oh nice save by hu this will be it yeah
this be a big one from the car if he gets
it and the overall save H goers are just so
good seven saves so auton Jer bosski still
your leaders in the go Department only one
man can beat them and he has to go against
Conor McDavid but first here's ma against
heluk that first shot by by Mar scoring there he
let that go so quick and so accurate no chance for
hellu but bounced back and great performance
by huk there as well Mar's Alma Mo UMass did
win tonight while UMass low fell to Bon Collin
number one team of the country so here it is
our leader Conor McDavid has a nice nicely too
if he wins this one be in great position to win
the whole Fame and the obstacle course of course
the obstacle course is going to be his best best
event it's the all unless his blade falls off
his skate here he comes my goodness he's going
hard oh poke cheek great poke check oh now he's
got him thinking about getting too close nowes
can't get too tight exactly that was the first
poke check of the night wasn't in Conor's brain
another one another one I tell you that should
play without a stick in this competition that'd
be skill oh oh that was a good shot look at him
cover ground he's are worth two points oh with
this speed he probably has time for incredible
amount of ground oh try to go five ball no six
saves because of the speed of McDavid gorev can
pick up a number of saves that's seven he's two
saves away from winning 100 Grand he going get
a two shots in hereo he is oh so gorv will win
100 Grand if he makes this save it's a $100,000
save for [Applause] gorv check him again nine
of 11 and he wins one 00,000 the Poke check was
his friend kept him away from the [Applause] de
again he wins 100 Grand courtesy the PO check
mess right there you can see him to Chang his
old attempts for McDavid there were some of your
opponents who poke checked well against you back
in the day oh my goodness uh Ron Ronnie XTO
Kevin weeks is with our $100,000 winner I'm
standing here with Alex gorv of the Colorado
Avalanche who looked a little bit like the late
great Johnny Bower or maybe like arur B with
the Poke check and you change the color the
blade tape on the stick tell us what happened
uh just try not to look like a barly goalie to
be honest uh yeah just trying to compete there
and uh enjoy the moment uh and just play them
fair you certainly did that so 100 Grand that's
that's a lot of cream what are you going to do
with that 100 Grand you going to do anything for
the boys what are you going to do uh you put me
on the spot there uh yeah I have to I have to
put a little bit and uh uh I haven't made any
plans but it's it's really cool experience for
sure awesome stuff you can always say that you
Stone Conor McDavid and you ended up winning 100
Grand congrats Georgie great stuff thanks a lot
awesome good stuff back to you bchi awesome
yeah pretty good night's work for 100 grand
so JT Miller and Nathan McKinnon now depart
after they missed the cut after round two PK
suban sitting down next to Willie Styles PK are
we on we're here all right here I am with William
neander doing it in Big Willie Style fashion
in his town in Toronto representing listen
you're three points behind McDavid you and Austin
Matthews can win this thing how do you feel about
that yeah I think that that shootout was huge for
us to get back at back in the competition for sure
okay also just this is just off the cup rumor has
it you're one of the best looking guys in the NHL
which means you probably one of the best looking
guys in sports how do you feel about that I don't
know about that rumor but uh I'll take that thanks
Willie all right so here are our current standings
with one event remaining for $1 million in the
end JT Miller wins the tiebreaker over leus Pon
and so McDavid marelle neander Matthews Ma and
Miller it's tight it's anybody's million dollars
PK and weeky it certainly is thanks BCI we're
down here at ice level on the bench and we've
got PK PK what are your thoughts right now we've
got the remaining fellas right now we got Big
Poppy beside you here we got big poy a how did
you get that nickname Big Poppy is it Big poppy
poppy Chula what is it poppy just poppy uh yeah my
mom gave it to me when I was like born basically
and just they called me Poppy and that's all like
growing up in Arizona that's all anybody knew me
at the rink like nobody knew me by Austin it was
just Poppy I love that there you go po Poppy I
love it I love it I love it but I like to mix in
the poppy Chulo every now and then when he's on
a two game when he's on a heater a lot of little
heater okay let's get some predictions here who do
you have winning the rest of this honestly I have
the hometown guys I think it's going to be either
Willie or or Austin Matthews and he's right here
I think they're going to step up they're saving
some energy for this last one a lot of pressure
on McDavid let's see how he hand don't sleep on
barzel though don't sleep on barel yeah Bar's
he's he's nasty all right bchi mess back up to
you where the sheets reside back up to you what
are the rules of the obstacle course announcer
man one final event with everything on the
line the Pepsi NHL obstacle course is all
that stands between our Allstars and a skills
Title First our skaters will show off their
speed again but this time car a puck then
we'll see stick handling through a series
of light up Bridges from there it's a test
of passing Precision into three mini Nets
then our Allstars will race to the cone course
and the event ends with a shot to a Target in
the net fastest time through the course wins
the final challenge with double the points up
for grabs tally up the scores and the allstar
with the highest total takes home the million
dooll prize so that means 10 points to the
winner which means everybody's in see leas
pson is out that's because the tiebreaker
JT Miller had a second so between Miller and
Pon and he did better in the one-on-one result
as well so we'll go in descending
order that means JT Miller will go
first in the obstacle course kind of like
the old school Superstars remember that on
ABC sure do the last event was always the
obstacle course remember watching Wayne
Gretzky in that and Y tore the competition up
remember Lin Swan we used to hurdle the high
jump everybody else used to somersault Lin
Swan ran right over it he won every year all
right so JT Miller obviously needs a big time
finish only five points out of the lead 10 n
876 for first through fifth the dude with the
most points with $1 million the other players
can kind of get a refresher course of what I'm
going to do taking the puck around now through
the little around the greens through the greens
around the blues there you go some sauce into the
Nets it's got to be tough mess huh oh
incredibly tough this one should be
easy it's a big it's a big wide one
got it Time Event around the Pepsi
[Applause] cans and you got
to shoot it right through the
middle that should not be a problem yeah
although they don't normally aim for the
logo so 49.3 51 again until you see someone really
do much better you're not sure what a good time
is I don't think that uh time's going to stand
up now I think so looked a little sluggish got
a mixed up on a few of the uh Gates down here
so let's uh see Willie neander is going to yep
I think Will's going to step up here step up
there and put a put a mark on the board that
everybody can shoot for this is where McDavid
probably will build a lead right because this
first ring round he's going to have so much
speed faster anybody else's nobody can do this
better than McDavid I unless he something his
blade falls off his skate uh yeah maybe Mar Ma
and barzel probably with their skating is the
one the two guys that could maybe hang so Mar
is going to go [Applause] first David just
can do it at such high speed under control
stick handling Puck handling edging three
players are 12 points so they probably fig
out the tiebreaker on who actually goes first
find those green ones and go between them oh
he lost there there you go floats it through
floats it through find the greens gets that
one through now this is going to be a big part
of the competition someone goes three for three
he'll probably win three for four three for
five okay now the wheels of Mard through the
cans he's going to beat
Miller he'll be the new leader as long
as he scores that's the big thing here
got to put it in and it is so he's your new leader
[Music]
43.436962 again it's a finish still Gass Here
Comes poppy poy Austin Matthews enough to a
good start here get to the targets he's got great
hands you can see him getting those little Nets
in three for three got to get through clean to
win this BCI no doubt about it he thre there
through the obstacles here obviously through the
lighted Gates get the targets down quick find the
green ones boom boom boom use the momentum of the
puck get Malin style clean now can he go three
for three one oh he miss hit the pad oh oh Austin
one more to go oh it's to post well this is going
to be the uh tough rck Austin now let's see how
he finishes here through the cans and into the
net stamina is a part of this obstacle course
some guys burn out early mess he's not going
to catch the car car will hang on to oh look
at that that saves time BCI is sweet he knew
he was behind exactly his only chance was
to save two seconds which he probably did
with that lengthy shot EAS two seconds yeah and
that passes Miller and he's in second confidence
up with the confidence to take the shot from
there that's some swag this is so cool boom
pump it and boom save himself a second maybe
second and a half teammate Willie Styles is
next as Matthews can only hope now that that
second place hangs on that would give him
nine points in 21 you see the live standings
it won't be good enough he can't pass ma car
I see neander having a good run so Mar the
only chance for a million but of course we
have other participants remaining who could pass
him naner is going he wants this just signed the
new be contract extension in front of the fans
they were afraid they were going to lose Willie
but he stuck around with the big eight-year
extension gets through cleanly this is where
he can win it this is the spot that's the real
Difference Maker look at the nice touch no okay
go he's going too oh he wants it Will's given 100%
this is why they put the million dooll prize come
on this is why oh a stumble that could cost them
he might have to shoot from distance it's going to
be close oh no he can't do bless his heart he
must be the sickest man in Canada oh he had a
chance at it he had to hit it oh I love the effort
from William neander that was awesome this is what
Conor McDavid was talking about I love the compete
so good just didn't see that in years pass really
good he is absolutely Gass look at the death touch
though just a little sauce over there oh it just
fell off the toe and it was he lost it right
here B on the target uh on the sauce [Music]
Target so there's the live
scoring barzel as you can see
see he could pass ma with a second uh-huh
that would give him [Applause] 22.5 but
obviously he'd like to make sure he passes
Mar's time yeah then make McDavid beat him
then make McDavid beat him exactly here we
go should be a good event beautiful stride
yeah he's got speed of course he's got amazing
hands lots of marinara in these Ms clean as a
whistle mess here it is this is the Difference
Maker who will go three for three or three for
four the Miss went for the big net first and
he missed it both times oh boy no no just get
one get one pulling them no oh this is
where it gets tough right you hear the
crowd moan you're getting tired your spirit
has been sucked out of your body he going
to ride a pucks well they're going to bring
more over just in casage here comes the pck
caddy we did not expect this
no oh my god oh poor Manny is that it no just
finish off you never know abely someone could be
worse yeah this is where you got to dig deep
and play just finish it for PR if you ain't
first you're last at the skills competition
in Toronto last too bad he was set out for a
good time he did everything else really that's
Prov to be that's proven to be the hurdle right
down it is that little net is n but you got
to just stick with one and hit that he missed
the first couple then he went to a different
Target then he got a little bit of way off
balance there you got to stick with the same one
till you hit it second place is eight points in
this round muscle memory bie muscle memory stay
with the first one eight points gets McDavid the
[Music] win I guarantee he's got a little
adrenalin run right now bii competitive
as he is so here it is getting crowned him
he's got to beat mat 47.2 that's his time
been debating it but now we're going to
find out well a lot of people called this
the Conor McDavid Invitational if there was
no salary cap on the Range do we pay him 50
million so this is a way to get Conor an
extra million bucks let's see I think he
wants to win 47 seconds for a million doll
that's a good start oh just misses the this
is the narrow one this is the hardest one he
got it now this is an easy one for him that's
a piece of cake he's going to do it just don't
fall down Conor you're going to win a million
don't fall down Connor and put the biscuit in the
basket $1 million shot here it is oh no problem
what a performance what a performance by what
we thought was the best player in the National
Hockey League debatable maybe for some but now
we know BCI incredible incredible I love the
compet $1 million to Conor McDavid the
man who help reimagine the event bring
some juice some drama mission accomplished how
about the professionalism though
the compete that he shown just
incredible a little rough
through the stick handling
portion wo bar out was probably ahead of him at
this point but McDavid got the first net and then
finished off no problem just had a finish it
off here that was a unbelievable unreal what
a performance all right the runner up was Kell
marar he's with our Kevin weeks yeah he's won
everything in this league he's won everything in
the game and he was outstanding in this once again
take us through your run yeah just a little bit
of a rough rough start on the kind of Puck cones
there and uh knew just that knew that was going
to be the dagger so there's one guy to beat today
and it was him and do it what do you think of the
new setup I loved it this was awesome I mean you
get to do a couple extra things uh it's pretty
late right now but uh no it was awesome like
just being able to interact with these guys and
then be able to contri or kind of compete in all
these events was a lot of fun I think these guys
have fun here too so uh definitely something to
keep in the back pocket for NHL fans hopefully
any family here from Calgary taking it in for
All-Star Weekend yeah some parents and stuff was
giv him a little look after that was a little bit
a tough one but uh knew it wasn't going to come
out my way when he's going last so still a lot
of fun and kind of lost to a better guys though
great stuff long way from elbow Park keep it going
yeah I appreciate you so kale marar close second
place to our champion caror McDavid McDavid with
PK suban 1 million bones 1 million balloons
PK all right I'm here with with Conor McDavid
Connor I'm sitting on the bench with JT Miller and
J looks at you and he looks at me and week he goes
one run for a million dollars and it seems like
every single time you're on the ice you're faced
with the pressure the adversity to step up put
your team on your back represent your city you
do it how does it feel to be a millionaire now
and how do you do it every time yeah you know
obviously there's money on the line and it's fun
um you know special to go up against all these
guys here 12 12 of the best hockey players in the
world and um like I said we were here to put on a
show and hope the fans enjoyed it um I know I did
well you're a consumate professional and you know
what for a lot of kids there's a lot of kids
watching you're a great example Conor McDavid
best player in the world right now folks shows it
again today shout out to Edmonton Oilers thanks
Conor appreciate that there we go Conor mcdavis 16
wins in a row currently they'll go for their 17th
in a row on ESPN plus Tuesday then he wins his
skills competition it's pretty good to be Conor
McDavid right now who breaking news already was a
millionaire just so PK knows he was already Milli
that's true I just can't I just keep getting
back to the same thing you know you come into
these events of course everybody's a great hockey
player of course everybody wants to do well but
being able to do it well when the pressure is
on and in the moments the biggest Conor McDavid
came in here he was an instrumental in changing
the format had a big say in it and then came
out here and delivered it was just incredible
to watch what a performance by him and showed
why he's the best player in the in the National
Hockey League and of course the best player in
the world getting the big check from Bill Daly $1
million now next on his agenda win a Stanley Cup
that's what uh he's going to be putting all his
focus in to win a Stanley Cup and uh I'm sure at
some point in his career he's going to do it for
Mark Miss I'm John bu Steve Levy take us home all
right bie excellent job from the main broadcast
Booth here with Ray Ferraro Ray we didn't learn
anything tonight because we knew Conor McDavid
was the best player on the world and he proved
that once again here tonight nothing changed I
think Conor mcdavid's the most evolved player
of all time I think he's the greatest player
that's ever played the game I think the game
will show that in history you watch him today
Nate McKinnon said last year he's so much better
than everybody else and then you watch it when
they're all together and it's just remarkable to
watch him just think since just before Christmas
mcdavid's won 16 straight games and a million
bucks has not lost since before the Christmas
season and McDavid said he enjoyed tonight kale
marar said he liked all the new changes NHL did a
really good job they got that right tweaking the
allstar skills competition so we're 2third of the
way through this Allstar Weekend in Toronto the
Crown Jewel comes tomorrow the Honda NHL allstar
game we'll see you all at 300 p.m. Eastern on ABC
it's been a special night Conor McDavid he is your
champion and don't forget about Alex gorv he won
the goal tending competition 100 Grand to him a
million to McDavid thanks everybody for watching